-You were nominated for an Oscar
for "Benjamin Button."
-Yes.
-And that is a film --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I did not realize this.
You -- you got a callback
after your first audition
and you did not want
to go to the callback.
-Yeah, because by that point
in my career, I knew
that the audition room
is just so the casting directors
can save their ass,
so to speak.
You know, because they have
already gone out to the stars.
-Yeah.
-They're just waiting
for one to bite the bait.
And so they do these auditions,
just in case the star doesn't --
or whoever the list is.
I knew I wasn't on that list.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ] Because I was
in the audition room.
So, I just knew --
I knew I'd been on a million
auditions and I was like,
they are going to have me
go through this,
pour my guts out in front
of this strange person,
and leave my guts in there,
and then they're going to hire
somebody else.
-Sure.
-You know, so I was done.
And I said, I'm having
a yard sale today.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it was Saturday!
-Was this a previously
scheduled yard sale?
-Yes!
-Okay.
-Flyers had gone out.
Champagne had been ordered.
I had --
-Wait, what kind of yard sale
are you --
-Oh, you got to
get 'em drunk, honey.
-Okay, gotcha.
-You got to get 'em drunk.
-Oh, so they walk in
and the champagne's just out.
-I pop the bottles right away,
get them nice and drunk.
-Okay.
-And then, I'm like,
"Girl, take it all!"
[ Laughter ]
-So in the end, though,
you did --
did you cancel the yard sale?
-I had to.
-Yeah.
-David Fincher was calling.
So I went begrudgingly.
-[ Laughs ]
-And I thought that it was going
to be like other -- a callback,
like, you know, several other
actresses that did a good job.
And I went in
and it was a ghost town.
It was literally the audition --
it was just so I could meet
David Fincher.
-Oh, wow.
-Laray Mayfield, I love you!
-That's great.
-'Cause she casts
all of his films.
-Now tell me how soon after that
did you reschedule
the yard sale?
-I was like, "Y'all,
we just going to open --
"I'm going to open up
the doors today,
but just a couple
of hours later."
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
And I want to ask,
because we've talked before
about how Cookie is
a character that you play
that so many people fell in love
with immediately, and --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, of course.
-Thank you.
-And you have --
a lot of fans
are drawn to Cookie
and inspired by Cookie.
And not just female fans,
is that true?
-That is very true.
There's this tweet, and I wish
I had took a screenshot of it.
This was a man, and I guess
he worked in corporate America.
But he was like,
"I wish I had the balls
"to kick in that door
in that boardroom meeting
and walk in there like Cookie."
I was like, "This is the best
tweet ever."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, we could use more Cookie.
-I think so.
-All of us could use a little
more inner Cookie.
-I think Cookie
lives in all of us.
-Yeah.
-It's just that you have to
choose to tap into her.
-Yeah, she just is -- she's
inside of us, imprisoned.
-Yes, exactly. Exactly!
That's a good one.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
-It's always
such a pleasure to see you.